this is this is why I'm on supervised
release hey how is your probation
officer doing you know what I was
thinking was funny I actually thought
about this and I thought there's no way
she even the suggestion she'd be
irritated I mean I was thinking Danny I
should suggest to Danny that she that he
asks her to come on the podcast oh yeah
she'd never do it no I know she would
never do it yeah she's already told me
basically right I don't know that she
can't but I think her whole thing is
she's like I don't want to be famous do
you understand like she doesn't like it
when I mention her she's like like oh
she doesn't said don't mention me again
yeah but she's like you do understand
mr. Cox I don't want to be famous right
I heard the podcast last night you
mentioned me I don't want to be famous
that I'm like yeah I know I feel real
bad about that
sorry about that so my bad they asked me
you know what am I gonna say but she's
I'll bet you she's got some stories I
think people will be into it just like
hearing the people in your orbit who
have the stories about you to get maybe
some of the details that you're leaving
out or to get just a different
perspective on it I think would be
really interesting oh she's she's she's
she's I don't feel like she trusts me
she probably doesn't like we have we
don't we're not close like that I feel
like they feel like she's she's very
she's probation did somebody donate a
hundred Norway money's yeah that was a
hundred bucks it Norway money's what do
they call it maybe six dollars somebody
converted it to nine dollars and one
cent not 71 oh that's cool thank you
read their comments yeah yeah I got it I
got some comments from the people who
are paying for their questions
appreciate you know you're paying for
the crab and we are super grateful for
it I'll be here soon this one comes from
Joseph Berkeley Matt what element of the
con did you enjoy the most
was it the money or did you get more of
a rush by duping the system
you know I hate for it really you know
why it's horrible because I'll answer it
and I'll get 40 people that'll be like
oh this guy's awesome he's amazing and
I'll get one guy that's like this guy's
a [ __ ] scumbag lowlife bragging piece
of [ __ ] they should have killed him and
I was like I'm like no matter what
you're yeah that's everything the
Internet that's everything especially if
you're gonna have like the number one
trending scammer site on YouTube you're
gonna be getting a lot of that thick
skin well I'm pretty thick-skinned but
it's still a lot of times it's like you
know they're talking about chopping
somebody's head to offer you should bury
him under the bridge like you know you
the other you're more than an anger
management problem that's why you're in
the bat-cave mm-hmm you don't put
yourself out there cuz you know so what
what is your answer to that that's
probably gonna be that that it's gonna
be me doing this and that's going to be
the what would be the best that's a hard
question bro because honestly look fight
a million dollar at one I like 1.3
million in the bank I've had a million
in the bank I've had I I didn't I didn't
live in a million dollar house a lot of
commas I wasn't living in I wasn't
living in a half a million dollar condo
I wasn't driving a Lamborghini you know
I was driving in a decent sports car
well not not red silver black something
very what kinds I mean I mean I've had
I've had outies I've had Mercedes I've
had of what infinities but you know
those are just those aren't like amazing
cars there's 60 $70,000 they're not it's
not a 300 to half a million four hundred
thousand dollar Lamborghini right
because they never but looking at you
and people start asking questions and
then so you know just something
something nice
yeah labor Gainey's like over the line
Lamborghini everybody I've known five
guys that have had Lamborghinis every
one of them that didn't you just meet
two guys who drove twin to twin Tories
who are those guys that the plastic
surgery times a surgery you had them on
the Bubba the Love Sponge what's a twin
for
well these are twin brothers right they
both do plastic surgeries no no one has
matching Ferraris one does black plastic
surgery but they're both attorneys and
they both had black Ferraris but when I
told them when I mentioned they were
they were matching they go no no they're
actually different a lot of guys from
the billboards that look exactly yeah
yeah they are there yeah because now
they're both they they're lawyers
they're both Diaco
one of them has a goatee and the other
doesn't that's how you tell him apart oh
really I didn't know I'll check the
billboard next time bye it does a creepy
uh what was it was it was it winters and
no it was the [ __ ] last names
was it Diaco or was it winters and
Jonker no there's no the ACOs the Tiago
because he did the TV he put the titties
on the nut girl
no don't let's not say that don't ever
do that we're live there's no editing
now yeah don't
that's just mean-spirited you're killing
me so listen okay so what would be the
best part I mean what would you say
listen the bass the best part for me
honestly and you tell me it's this she
says why can't I find the live version
really who said that my ex-wife she's
funny so it's how do i how do I send the
link just text it to her okay what's
with that's the link I just put concrete
yeah I'll text you a link right now yeah
keep going keep going all right all
right so listen is it fooling somebody I
don't know I listen there was no bigger
thrill than walking in the bank putting
down an ID that was issued by the state
of Florida or South Carolina North
Carolina you walk in you put down your
driver's license you hand them all the
fake documents you sign some documents
they hand you a check for $250,000 and
then they thank you for ripping them off
and tell you and tell you you've been
the best customer I've ever worked with
with mr. blackwell thank you thank you
very much all right well Lee you have a
good day Jennifer you have a good day
too and walking right out
let's face it there's just that's
amazing walking through passport control
and giving them a passport and they go
mr. Sullivan are you here for business
or pleasure you're like I'm here for
pleasure and they're like okay well
thank you mr. Sullivan thank you very
much and sign here and you're good
thank you you walk out you're like you
feel like James Bond oh yeah so is it
the thrill I would have to say it is the
thrill it's not that I'm trying to make
somebody look bad it's just that you're
it's amazing that I guess that you're
getting away with it and of course you
walk out you get into a nice car you go
stay at a nice hotel you're dating an
amazing looking chick you're you've got
tons of money I mean it's a great
feeling you know I mean you know so I
mean is it it would have to be the
thrill right I mean it's because it's
not the money because I wasn't living
like a like a multi-millionaire or
anything wasn't blowing money I wasn't
driving a Ferrari I mean I'm just anyway
if she if Shane had $50,000 in the bank
he'd be driving a Ferrari are you saying
to me okay cool next question awesome
you got more money questions yeah we got
more money questions tell Danny to
shotgun a beer don't you paid five bucks
for that tell me to shotgun a beer mmm
I'm not shotgunning the beer for five
bucks yeah [ __ ] that holy name I'll eat
a crab leg for five I think you're up to
I'm already like five deep Matt you want
a shotgun a Starbucks for five bucks
from Regina looks like it's got alcohol
in it no hell no Lua
right Kahlua is gaya doesn't it it's
like coffee right yeah that's not good
let's check on the crab see where the
table shot this is pretty good I figured
you'd like white chocolate
[Music]
oh man will you go out and get it for us
yeah
get me my crab so it's one two what's
the next question your waitress sexual
today I they're all printed what's
metrosexual it's like to me it's it's
somebody who's like a guy that's like so
into himself he's almost like a girl
like he gets everything has to be so and
he gets face peels and well it's kind of
like well sounds more like Oh sod wait
what's your name Sam Sam Sam what's a
metrosexual
she's never Mike which C well you got a
plaster you've got what is the
definition of a metrosexual a young
urban heterosexual male with liberal
political views and interest in fashion
and a refined sense of taste I'm jogging
right I look a cell phone an iPhone this
is like one of the big nice like like
wow like pick it up I look around
nobody's there it's on the sidewalk I
wait about five minutes listen to the
radio
okay finally I call Stacy and I go hey I
found an iPhone how do I find out whose
it is and she goes is it locked I said
yeah it's the thumbprint thing she was
okay well take it with you they'll call
you eventually
so I'm jogging back a jog for like five
or ten minutes somebody calls the cell
phone I pick up the cell phone I answer
it
the woman says did you find a cell phone
I said yeah that's found your cell phone
she's oh gosh I go where are you and she
said I'm here I said okay I'm here and
she says okay well how can you bring it
to me I went whoa I'm five ten minutes
away you're here can you
you meet me halfway just just head down
it was a Belle Lake Road and she goes
well I'd have to cross the street then I
went oh well we wouldn't want that I
said uh okay I'll bring it to you
so I jog all the way back there I give
her the cell foot listen this is a I
thought well maybe she's maybe she's in
a wheelchair I don't know like I don't
know yeah she didn't want to cross the
road what yeah it was Collier I mean it
was it's two lanes it's not a big deal
anyway the point that's not gonna happen
so I gave her the phone there's a like a
little butt on the side of the iPhone
yeah and if you hit it if you switch it
it'll make your phone silent and it just
vibrates when people call it doesn't
bother me it's really cool he's a really
cool invention
I mean guy well we are like on a talk
show I mean killing me bro so what are
you doing so anyway yeah I give her the
phone she book she just takes the phone
shoes thank you and turn it on walks off
I just jogged you couldn't cross the
road
you're like would she look like I mean
she was frumpy you know what frumpy
looks like it's not good little baggy
yeah she needed that she should have met
me halfway she needed to meet yeah I
know that sounds mean-spirited but the
fact that matter is she was a bigan
anyway the bikes yeah yeah nothing you
know I not here's the thing like Stacey
goes she's trying to give you some money
I said well no and I thought you know
what I'm not gonna take any my like you
she said let me give you $20 I would I'd
be like no no of course I don't want but
it'd be nice if you offered I found your
phone I returned your phone jog did you
I jog jog back like Kim it and now I
have to go back again double time
listen I'm not being nice anymore it's
Karma my therapist tells me oh you have
to do selfless acts and everything
that's over over they say no more
selfless no good deed goes unpunished
sure what's the next question
wait I have something that is probably
the best thing I've seen in the live
chat from Daniel Gmail we have
confirmation on what metrosexual is nice
and should be defined as from here on
out someone who is sexually attracted to
trains
Oh Sharon Metro literally it's a silly
name for a train it's just silly
Thank You Daniel Thank You Daniel Gmail
all right next question I doesn't really
went off the rails there all right we
got a Bobby underscore McCutcheon how
much left of your restitution is there
to pay what's a good question five
million nine hundred G's nine hundred
and seventy thousand I paid off about
paid off about a little over 30 - how
close to 35 maybe thirty five thousand
really I had a job I mean I'm not I
didn't have a job I was thirty five
thousand since win when did you start
paying it oh no that was almost
instantly they were selling stuff also
when I got the six million a month or
two later they had sold some stuff off
so they went towards restitution sold
some stuff like my cars you know like no
they'd already sold all that like they
sold all that none of that went towards
restitution and and the restitution that
they hit me with they wanted they were
saying nine point five million and I was
arguing I've never seen nine point five
million that's ridiculous
yeah I never got nine point five million
so we start arguing yeah and we got them
down to six million they were like well
is it this much I'm like and they're
like look the FBI saying it's 11 and a
half billion we went nine point five I'm
like so we went back and forth and I got
it two to six million but then as soon
as that my sentencing was over they were
selling stuff off they ended up selling
some vacant lots or something and they
got like 30 grand in and then since then
I've been paying I pay $150 a month no
matter what you have to pay 150 and then
anything I pay 25 percent of anything I
make over $2,000 so I pay 115 if I make
an extra if I make 3,000 its 150 plus
25% of the extra thousand so it's 250
plus 150 so it's whatever 400 you know
that's 400 bucks so I've been paying 360
two hundred five hundred 150 you know
I've only been doing that for about a
year I don't know what that's come to
it's maybe come to two or three grands
like that not that much I mean you know
what do you what are you gonna do
[Music]
[Laughter]